hey guys why don't we start with a quick
game of would you rather tony how about
we start with you
would you rather eat nothing but plain
yogurt for the rest of your life or suck
off your dad
okay let's not play that game amazon's
latest drama the wilds
lovingly referred to as teen lost sees
eight young women from completely
different backgrounds come together to
survive stranded on an island but with
mysterious events
secret operatives and even shark attacks
things aren't what they seem
in this video we'll be going over season
one uncovering some of its
biggest mysteries like where is nora
what is the twilight of adam
and theories on what to expect for
season two so you'll want to stick
around for that
agreed so make sure your tray table's up
and seat's in the full upright position
oh yeah you'll probably want to click
like and subscribe too
because here we go welcome to gynotopia
don't ask me i did not come up with that
name the world's
first all-female lead community at the
end of 12 weeks we will have seen
gynutopia in action or at least that's
what the head of the dawn of eve
gretchen klein says while practicing one
of her speeches
throughout the course of the season we
learned that these eight women stranded
on the island are here for one
big social experiment one which seeks to
prove that women when faced with
adversity
hardship and conflict will work together
to solve their problems rather than
men who would resort to violence to hell
with male domination that has turned
this planet into a war-torn
money-hungry fireball she wants to prove
scientifically that women are superior
leaders who will work towards diplomacy
and mutual cooperation
rather than lashing out with violence
for her the biggest evil in the world is
the patriarchy a system of society or
government
in which men hold the power and women
are largely excluded from it but why
all this hatred for men what would spur
a woman to create one of the most
elaborate expensive
and illegal experiments of all time in
the final episode we learned gretchen
had a son named devin
we never get to see devin but we learn
he was responsible for the murder of
norah's boyfriend quinn in a hazing
incident gone wrong
gretchen believes her son was
manipulated by toxic masculinity
theta [ __ ] kappa theta and their
toxic male
[ __ ] she tried to raise her son
right taught him about consent read him
poems and attended women's marches
but the power of the patriarchy was too
strong i'm not saying
he isn't to blame but the patriarchy and
its institutions
sure aren't innocent so part of
gretchen's reason to make this project
is for her to feel some sort of
redemption for raising a violent son
so that this violence caused by toxic
men can end once and for all
but gretchen's methods aren't exactly
legal she has to lure a group of teenage
girls by promising them
and their parents who would not be
attending a retreat in hawaii that is
supposed to foster women
empowerment it's all an elaborate ruse
as she fakes a plane crash to get these
girls on an island
and force them to work together throwing
them increasingly difficult milestones
to challenge them and build a sense of
community
but at some point it just sort of
clicked it wasn't like we were friends
or anything but
the first time we were in us but
gretchen can't do it all on her own
within the group are two plants or
operatives that will help guide the
experiment the first is jeanette well
that's her fake name her real name is
lynn bach a
university student hired by gretchen who
shares her sentiments about toxic
masculinity jeanette was drugged and
assaulted by men at a party one night
that's why when she sees leah passed out
the day the girls are being shipped off
to the island she gets triggered
briefly having second thoughts about
going through with the experiment
gretchen sees something in jeannette the
two share a close bond and almost have a
mother-daughter dynamic perhaps
jeannette fills the void her son in
prison has now
left that's why when jeannette dies in
episode 1 it hits her especially hard
she voluntarily puts herself in a psych
ward and we see her imagine the light
flickering
she also has a constant itch which is
never fully explained but
could be caused by constant stress we do
know she has stress
issues as the beginning of one episode
she visits a spa
only to scream at the top of her lungs
with jeanette gone gretchen decides to
keep going ahead with the experiment as
they have a second
fail-safe operative it isn't until
episode 9 that we find out this person
is
nora nor like gretchen is motivated to
see a world where toxic masculinity
doesn't exist
and there's a two reasons for this one
her boyfriend quinn was killed in a
fraternity hazing ritual gone wrong
and two she's had to deal with her
sister's eating disorder a result of
societal pressure for her to look a
certain way
each episode of the season focuses on
the backstory of a specific character
relating their story to an event that's
happening on the island the final
episode focuses on nora and we see what
led her to become this operative and how
she helped sway the events on the island
for example she was responsible for
planting the bag of medication
which shelby would eventually find in
episode 9 aliyah in a super from alcohol
and
edibles finds nora talking to
headquarters via one of the island's
many hidden cameras this starts the
events that will eventually lead to this
season's cliffhanger with leah's
discovery that nora is working for some
organization that is watching them nora
ends up trapping leah seeing as she
could jeopardize the whole experiment
we'll find out later this goes terribly
wrong meanwhile shelby and tony wake up
after having spent the night together
shelby has been coming to terms with her
own sexuality this season
coming from a strict christian household
which condemns homosexual behavior
she has been forced to choose between
being her authentic self
and the person her family wants her to
be nora hints at this in episode 4 when
shelby recites her favorite monologue
from death of a salesman
a monologue that now means so much more
he's telling his father that he doesn't
want to live for him anymore that he
wants his own authentic life
it's also interesting to see shelby
picking fruit considering
all the religious symbolism here the
dawn of eve the twilight of adam adam
and eve
shall be picking the forbidden fruit
just like her feelings towards other
women are forbidden tony herself has
also had to open up
in her backstory we see how she was
rejected by her love and because of that
prefers to be alone so she can never get
hurt again
yeah when you're by yourself you can
only hurt yourself
i'd call that safer martha has also
changed throughout the season her story
is the perfect example
of how what's happening on the island
reflects her life back home
on the island martha is the protector of
animals and doesn't want to go through
with killing the goat even though they
need it for food
in other words she's protecting
something that if killed
would be better for the greater good
this is reflected under protection of dr
ted a man who abused her and many other
girls as a child when asked to testify
against him in court she ultimately ends
up protecting them even though he hurts
so many young women martha killing the
goat is her finding her inner strength
to do what is right
this strength is symbolized as we see
her wearing her jingle outfit the one
she ended up leaving the day of her
competition when she couldn't muster the
courage to go through with it
these stories are told side by side with
fbi interviews that are conducted two or
three days after the girls are picked up
from the island
or at least that's what they're told by
these fbi guys that probably
aren't fbi at all it was gretchen after
all who hired them when leah asked agent
daniel faber where her parents are he
makes the excuse that they're currently
on route and the delay is the result of
proper visas needing to be acquired
as far as we know the parents haven't
been notified at all
in the final episode we learned the
girls are being held 800 miles off the
coast of peru
and 150 miles from the island that they
were stranded on or at least that's what
we're told
the girls are kept separate from one
another so the investigators can get all
their stories straight
but it isn't until shelby demands she be
taken to see leah that things start to
ramp up
at the end of episode 8 we see her slip
leah a note a note that says
you were right this is referring to her
being right about an organization
watching over them
and that one of them could be an
operative leah plans her escape by using
a piece of napkin given to her by agent
dean young
and stuffing it within the locking
mechanism that night
shelby experiences anaphylactic shock we
know that she's allergic to shellfish so
either a
she's faking this or b someone slipped
or something to create a diversion i
have a theory that agent dean young
could be helping with this escape he was
the one who gave leah the napkin
he would have had access to shelby and
he also has motive for these girls
getting out he makes it known to leah
that he has his own daughter that he's
being kept away from because of
gretchen he knows the pain of being
separated from a child
he even tells leah her time there won't
be long
but it won't last much longer look hand
to god it won't
another theory is that this is still
part of the experiment it's
it's still going on but how that fits
into gretchen's overall plan
is yet to be seen we also don't know if
there are more operatives at the end of
episode 3 we see gretchen recruiting dot
her father even mentions briefly that he
wants new gretchen that's how he found
out about this retreat
very odd that this story threat has
never picked up on for the rest of the
season then there's what happened to
nora it's highly implied that nora died
after trying to save her sister from the
shark attack a shark attack which
resulted in rachel losing her hand
nor is the only girl besides jeanette
who is not interviewed and rachel says
two interesting things about nora while
being interviewed
one she asked if her parents knew what
happened to nora
r.e her being dead and two you know what
i feel
it's her hand holding mine
the writers are wanting us to believe
she's dead but knowing how this show has
many twists and turns and nothing can be
ruled out one of the biggest mysteries
season one leaves us with is what
happens between the shark attack and
their extraction from the island
we never actually see leah expose nora
for being an operative
and the girls are separated as soon as
they leave so it's entirely possible
that none of the girls know about
nora's involvement in their captivity
then there's this question of
phase two when gretchen has asked what
to do about leah being held in that pit
she's also told that the rollout for
quote phase two
has absorbed all available watercraft
and it won't be until another three
hours that they can deal with leah
she also says this are you on your way
up top
yes supervision is my watch word this
time round
that's how we avoid any predicaments
this hints that gretchen likely has more
than one
island she's overseeing the first island
with the girls we've seen this season
was a failure hence why she's more
hands-on with this other one
and it could also explain why she went
to that rich donor to beg for more money
so phase two could actually mean three
things one a new island with new girls
two what the girls are currently going
through during these interviews
or three the twilight of adam during
lee's escape she uncovers a security
room with cameras focused on a control
group called the twilight of atom it's
basically an experiment just like the
girls went through but with
boys it's important to note this is
called a control group as
control groups are used in science to
compare it to other findings gretchen is
trying to show that this group of young
boys will devolve into violence
kind of like in lord of the flies while
a group of women faced with the same
exact hardships will work together and
build a community
in contrast we expect our subjects to
discover
a peaceful female-driven model of
governance
there are still a lot of questions here
like if these are simply recordings and
this control group has
already happened or if these are live
feeds i think going forward it will be
interesting to see how much gretchen
interferes with the experiments
to give her the results she wants she
seems pretty damn fanatical at proving
her point just
how far will she take it i want to hear
your thoughts and theories about this
season and the next
in the comments below thanks for
watching everyone be sure to like
subscribe and share and for more bad
takes you can always follow me on
twitter and instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much